non les dacquois ses membres du
gouvernement et membre du gouvernement
en ce moment et qui de confusion n'est
pas de quoi piquer pas m'ont mis des
finances
et bien nous nous intéresse pas sinon ça
sent qu est-ce qu on dise ont le don de
castanet
bonjour et bienvenue dans point de vue
le magazine de débats quotidiens du
figaro la sève rassurez vous je n'ai pas
fait un putsch à la zimbabwéenne pour me
débarrasser de guillon roquettes qui
reviendra dès mercredi
aux manettes de l'émission mais d'ici là
je vous propose tout de suite de voir le
sommaire des quatre thèmes que nous
allons aborder avec mes quatre invités
aujourd'hui
d'abord le remaniement ministériel
imminent dix ans à trouver un digne
successeur à christophe castaner au
poste de porte parole du gouvernement et
peut-être au secrétariat d'état aux
relations avec le parlement macron
va-t-il en profiter pour modifier son
gouvernement nous en parlerons avec mes
quatre invités à qui je demanderai qui
remaniée et que remanier selon rue nous
traverserons ensuite avec agilité le
rhin pour nous rendre en allemagne où
angela merkel se trouve en grande
difficulté après l'échec des
négociations cette nuit pour former une
coalition avec les libéraux et les
écologistes
d'où cette interrogation après tout
faut-il sauver le soldat ou plutôt la
générale merkel aux torts en france
ensuite avec cette invitation un peu
taquine de marine le pen à laurent
wauquiez à qui elle propose une alliance
politique le vraisemblable futur
président des républicains doit-il
répondent à la présidente du front
national mais invités vous diront ce
qu'ils en pensent et enfin nous
aborderons un sujet qui a beaucoup fait
tousser ce week-end justement faut-il
interdire la cigarette au cinéma comme
le suggère une sénatrice socialiste et
la ministre des solidarités de la santé
agnès buzyn en attendant la réaction de
la ministre de la culture qui est quand
même un peu concerné par le sujet je
vous demanderais là aussi leurs opinions
à mes invités mes invités qui sont ils
eh bien d'abord frédéric dabi le
précieux politologue directeur général
adjoint de l'ifop bons joueurs ils sont
2 les opinions les reins et les coeurs
de nos concitoyens très récemment
d'ailleurs vous avez publié un sondage
très intéressant sur la manif pour tous
5 ans après sa création la manif pour
tous et les français l'indispensable
daniel bilalian est aussi permis tout
parmi nous pardon ancien directeur des
sports de france télévisions une époque
où l'équipe de france de rugby glané
quelques victoires réellement
indispensable et plus beaucoup le cas
ancien présentateur du journal 20h et
auteur de ce formidable document ce qui
s'appelait les évadés aux éditions des
presses de la cité sur des exploits de
prisonniers de français de la seconde
guerre mondiale la rigoureuse bertille
bahia rédactrice en chef au service
économie et entreprise du figaro les
fameuses
pages saumon est également avec nous
tout comme l'intenable alexandre 2
vecchio animateurs du figaro vox
l'animateur du figaro box journalistes
aux pages débats opinions et auteur des
nouveaux enfants du siècle aux éditions
du cerf vous est aussi le cofondateur du
comité orwell alors madame messieurs
entre ont tout de suite dans le vif du
sujet avec l'actualité très chaude du
jour le remaniement gouvernemental
imminent
nous avons suivi ce week-end le congrès
de la république en marche qui a vu
christophe castaner et de propulser
propulsé pardon à la tête du mouvement
du parti on sait plus très bien comment
il faut l'appeler avec quand même cette
question peut-il dans ces conditions
rester à la fois au gouvernement comme
porte parole ça ne s'en doute pas
possible peut-être comme secrétaire
d'état au parlement et en même temps
délégué général puisqu'on n'a pas le
redire président de la république en
marche je vais vous demander votre avis
mais avant on a celui de benjamin
griveaux qui a donné son avis qui est
aussi secrétaire d'état au gouvernement
le délégué général dans une direction
collégiale du mouvement qui a été créée
par emmanuel macron je me permets de
mettre les bons mots sur les fonctions
qu'occupait christophe castaner à mon
avis ça n'est pas incompatible ça n'est
pas incompatible de pouvoir mener de
front le travail avec le parlement c'est
un travail au fond d'ingénierie
gouvernemental important et d'ingénierie
parlementaires adhérant des floraisons
frédéric dabi ça fait un petit peu
sourire quand on sait que benjamin
griveaux est plutôt favori pour
remplacer christophe castaner comme
porte parole
alors rappelons qu'il avait été porte
parole du mouvement en marche pour
l'élection présidentielle
qu'est ce que vous en pensez clairement
on est sur un sujet qui n'intéresse pas
vraiment les français on en parlait
avant l'antenne on va pas demain on
parle et on va en reparler dans le sens
où il ya une sorte d'action ou
adéquation qui fait les français
s'intéressent au sujet qui les concerne
donc la vie gay l'avis des organisations
partisanes
les concerts ne peut y intéressent peu
ona dans notre baromètre ifop fiducial
pour match une question extrêmement
intéressante une question qu'on est
d'avoir tous les mois qui concerne les
conversations des français
de quoi de quoi parler français et
systématiquement les événements liés à
la vie des partis arrivent en bas de
tableau le mois dernier justement la
probable élection de christophe castaner
ne recueillait que 16 ou 17 % de gens
nés par les mêmes auteurs ne produit pas
comme
les autres attendent un parti qui n'est
pas comme les autres c'est un parti qui
est pour tous pour les français une page
blanche et qu' une surface de projection
mais c'est surtout et là on n'est pas
seulement dans le nouveau monde comme
les parties de l'ancien monde c'est un
parti majoritaire et on sait très bien
que les français à l'époque de l'ump
pour nicolas sarkozy à l'époque du ps
pour françois hollande projette l'image
qu'ils ont du gouvernement sur le parti
majoritaire c'est peut-être l'enjeu pour
en marche et pour christophe castaner
s'est créé peut-être démarche de
différenciation et créer des éléments
d'image qui pour l'instant n'existe pas
et puis pourquoi je pense que les
français s'y intéresse pas ce que je
veux dire un peu trivialement il n'y a
pas de problème il ya cinq ans elle même
époque on parlait de couacs à tous les
étages sur tous les échelons ministériel
là on avait fait une enquête la semaine
dernière dans le journal du dimanche où
on voyait très bien on avait testé la la
satisfaction surtout des ministres il ya
très peu de différence auprès des
ministres les plus populaires et ceux
qui sont les moins populaires
ce gouvernement apparaît un peu comme un
pack un peu comme un soc pas ce que
c'était un gouvernement d'experts parce
que beaucoup de nuits sont très très peu
connue donc je dirais qu'à six mois six
mois après l'entrée en fonction des
manuels macron la question d'un
remaniement autant il pouvait s'imposer
avec une certaine acuité dans lé
quinquennat précédent autant c'est une
question qui apparaît relativement
secondaire vous êtes d'accord avec cela
daniel bilalian sachant que quand même
emmanuel macron n'est pas très haut dans
les sondages et peut-être qu'un
remaniement ministériel lui permettrait
de de regrimper un petit peu dans
l'opinion franchement je pense
effectivement comme la majorité de ses
ministres ne sont pas connues je pense
que le sujet ne se pose pas ils n'ont
pas encore fait leurs preuves et c'est
donc je vois pas pourquoi on changerait
des gens qui viennent de s'installer
dans leur bureau qui sont pour un
certain nombre des néophytes dont il n'y
a pas de ya pas eu de couac en termes de
de construction de la politique je vois
vraiment pas en quoi une par ailleurs
moi je ne vois pas pourquoi ce serait
gênant ce serait une première
effectivement qu'il reste ministre et en
même temps aux relations avec le
parlement
il ya eu dans le passé des milices comme
le foll qui était porte parole du
gouvernement et ministre de la culture
s'est un peu autre chose mais c'est un
peu mes tripes à des fonctions fréquence
et rossi c'est un peu aussi un mélange
des genres franchement en plus je pense
qu'on
autour cette table on est un peu
d'accord je dire on s'en fout et liberty
capable de faire histoire assure je
comprends que ça m'intéresse énormément
les les français cela dit ce n'est pas
inintéressant pour plusieurs raisons à
mon avis la première la presse
effectivement lisez il n'y a pas
beaucoup de clubs dans ce gouvernement
et sur cette histoire là la presse
regretter un petit peu le couac cela
fait partie un petit peu notre rôle la
deuxième chose je pense qu'effectivement
il y a il ya un sujet institutionnel qui
n'est pas un sujet inscrit dans la loi
mais effectivement la capacité d'un
homme politique à être à la fois un chef
de parti pour parole du gouvernement est
en charge des relations avec le
parlement ça le met quand même dans des
positions systématiquement ambigu qui
sont effectivement assez assez
particulière il y aurait une logique à
clarifier les choses et en même temps tu
aurais pas écrire l'inscrit en même
temps de penser qu'on n'est pas trop
loin mais c'est voilà ce gouvernement et
ce président qui met beaucoup de
détermination afficher son respect de
l'esprit et de la lettre des
institutions là pour le coup il se met
dans une situation avec un chef de parti
également en charge des relations avec
le parlement où il est censé avoir une
parole équitable quelque part vis-à-vis
de tous les partis politiques et de tous
les représentants du parlement là il se
met dans une situation un peu difficile
voilà donc je pense que les liens un cas
qui est qui qui a réglé avec un castaner
dont effectivement il n'a pas envie de
se priver non plus forcément au
gouvernement parce qu'il fait partie de
ces rares membres du gouvernement qui
sort un petit peu du lot dans la parole
publique dans la capacité d'expression
publique et c'est vrai que c'est un
élément et en plus est ce que c est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas au sein
du groupe en marche une personnalité qui
était capable de prendre cette affaire
en main c'est quand même un petit peu
dramatique
est-ce que ça surtout peut-être que
c'est emmanuel macron qui qui mènent
tous à alexandre de vaincus où il est
sain de en marche
le questionnaire ne sont qu'une
marionnette et à peu la marionnette
idéal
demain le plus le plus discipliné pour
macro et s'il a envie aussi que castanet
un resto au parlement c'est aussi pour
retenir tout simplement sa majorité donc
jeu voilà ce que ça révèle ce qui est
paradoxal et effectivement c'est qu'on
nous vendait le nouveau monde mais comme
le dit françois xavier bellamy dans
figaro parce qu'on est dans le nouveau
monde politicien est là bien plus après
moi ça me choque pas je croyais pas du
tout à la démocratie participative et à
l'horizontalité qui nous étaient vendus
mais ce qui est amusant c'est qu'on est
finalement dans un fonctionnement très
vème république presque gaulliste ou
foule
le parti est une machine de guerre au
service d'un homme
emmanuel macron à ce qui me plaît moi
c'est plutôt le cérémonial que j'ai vu
pour l'investiture de castanet on avait
l'impression que c'était le nouvel apple
castanet qu'on était c'est ce que je
faisais des ciels vichy on agitait dépôt
carte verte est donc là on se dit qu'on
est quand même dans un parti qui va pas
beaucoup réfléchir et qui sera d'un côté
post moderne comme ça qui n'a plus rien
à voir avec la politique avec un grand p
mais pour revenir sur le remaniement
ministériel vous aussi vous pensez qu'il
ya rien à changer personne n'a changé
dans ce gouvernement qu'il est
absolument parfait je pense que macro
surtout encore une fois a voulu faire le
poids lourd dont le poids loin le vide
de tout poids lourds politiques le seul
poids loire qu'il y avait c'était bayrou
il s'est débrouillé pour l'exfiltrer
donc je crois que pour l'instant c'est
efficace comme ça ma couette à grands
traumatisés du hall en dise où
effectivement il y avait des poids
lourds de chaque côté on essayait de
faire des synthèses des équilibres on
l'est entre les différents barons du ps
là il n'y a pas de barreaux il n'y a pas
deux poids lourds et finalement ça
permet pour l'instant à emmanuel macron
d'être tranquille le jour il sera
beaucoup plus affaibli dans les sondages
par contre il sera en première ligne et
là il sera peut-être temps de mettre les
poids lourds est ce qu'il y a la
possibilité que
macron aller chercher encore une fois
chez les républicains ou chez les
centristes une personnalité surprises
auxquelles on ne s'attend pas du tout
car je peux peut-être il peut en fait
percevoir mais aujourd'hui parce que
transformer il ya ce remaniement
technique au remaniement peu plus large
ça paraît peu vraisemblable alors mais
c'est une manière d'accélérer encore la
décomposition à droite mais déjà bien
après il faudrait enfin si d'aventuré il
fallait chercher quelqu'un
alors effectivement il devrait plutôt
aller chercher à gauche aujourd'hui et
on va pas de personnaliser à gauche
aujourd'hui qui émergent pour revenir au
gouvernement
aller chercher maintenant à nouveau
quelqu'un de droite la droite d'autres
pays quel qu'il soit ce ça renforcerait
le déséquilibre apparent donc on observe
aujourd'hui notre gouvernement d'autant
qu'à droits qui sont en train justement
ils viennent d'annoncer qu'ils créent un
nouveau parti qui s'appelle agir je
tourne les constructive de droite dont
edouard philippe serait l'un des
dirigeants voire le dirigeant donc dans
l'esprit cela mais à propos de poids
lourds devraient qu'on écoute ce qui a
dit bruno le maire selon bruno le maire
ce week-end qu'on peut considérer enfin
tout cas lui se considère comme un poids
lourd du gouvernement
non seulement je me suis engagé derrière
mu macron 2017
mais je souhaite c'est l'élection 2022
et je m'engagerai d'aia lui si jamais il
prend cette décision de se représenter
tout ça n'appartient qu'à lui
mais je serai derrière lui parce que je
pense que c'est dans le temps long que
nous réussirons notre ambition
collective fondée dhabi est ce que ça ce
n'est pas le propos de quelqu'un qui
pense qu'il peut être éjecté du
gouvernement qui fait allégeance pour
être bien sûr de rester dans un autre
extrait de l'émission juste avant pour
une balle au maire a fait part de son
assurance de rester ce qui est
extrêmement intéressant dans son propos
c'est la notion de temps dont il se
passe quelque chose qui en rupture avec
les quinquennat des quinquennat
précédent et qui est un vrai atout pour
emmanuel macron c'est que les français
qui ont été si un patient pour nicolas
sarkozy qui ont laissé très peu à
françois hollande
en difficulté dès septembre 2012 accorde
du temps long à emmanuel macron parce
qu'on a le sentiment qu'il agit on a le
sentiment qui tient parole les français
dans nos enquêtes et je fais référence à
celle du baromètre historique du jdd
publié hier on a un peu de français
disent que ça va mieux
très peu disent les choses vont mieux
sur la question du chômage mais et s'est
dit vraiment explicitement si la
déception des deux quinquennats
précédent vue l'idée que maintenant
voilà il ya peut-être plus que louis lui
ou le chaos
si je puis dire on lui laisse ou 1 on
inscrit dans le temps long et on le fait
sortir de la dictature de l'urgence qui
était si compliqué pour nicolas sarkozy
fracassé dix mois après son élection par
les élections municipales de 2001 qui
avait été très très mauvaise ou pour
françois hollande ça c'est une vraie
voter une opportunité pour lui parce
qu'il est maintenant sur un faux plat
jusqu'au sélection européenne de mai
2019 maintenant c'est extrêmement
cocasse de voir des questions sur la
présidentielle de 2000 22 alors que neuf
dixièmes du quinquennat longtemps encore
eu lieu c'est quand même extrêmement
d'être rejeté les questions quand même
bertille bahia est ce qu'il faut garder
bruno le maire dans ce gouvernement est
ce que à votre avis la question s'est
posée où la question se pose pour qu'il
réponde ça c'est quand même incroyable
justement il ya eu un épisode où on a
compris que bruno le maire était peut
être fragilisée autour de cette histoire
de taxes à 30 % sur les dividendes et du
rapport qu'il avait demandées dont
certains redoutaient qu'ils puissent
mettre en cause notamment emmanuel même
le rôle d' emmanuel macron quand il
était secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée on va dire que cet épisode est
derrière et moi dans cette réponse de
bruno le maire c'est un moyen assez
habile et lui pour le coup il a le
métier pour savoir esquivé les questions
auxquelles devront payer vos pas
répondre et donc là il arrive à ne pas
répondre à la question qui est est ce
que vous avez encore l'ambition d'être
un jour candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en se projetant
directement sur 2020 dont dix ont depuis
deux ans de toute façon sévère des
manuels macro et donc il ne répond pas à
la question initiale en réponse à ma
question
le maire est un bon ministre de
l'économie sans faux fuyant je pense que
oui je pense que oui
je crois que c'est important qu'il est
le poids politique qu'il a effectivement
à ce poste là qu'il est une adhésion à
priori assez facile l'essentiel du
programme et manière économique d'
emmanuel macron et notamment sur le plan
fiscal est là
revisite de la fiscalité du capital qui
était un point important et qu'il
n'avait pas forcément énormément le
monde pour réussir à tenir ce cap là au
moment où c'est un petit peu tanguay
quand même sur la suppression de l'sf
voilà après il faudra voir dans le temps
dans quelle mesure ils s'accommodent
effectivement de cette position de
premier violon économique emmanuel
macron mais que 1er alexandre vécu ou
pensée qui s'accommodera toujours d'être
le premier volet au violon et seulement
le premier volet violon je mets ma peur
de ce que j'aurai ce temps il a des
ambitions de premier ministre juste eu
mans puisqu'il constate qu'il ya
effectivement comme on le disait tout à
l'heure que deux poids lourds peu de
gens qui communiquent finalement dans ce
gouvernement
ici s'il verrait bien d'autant plus qu'
edouard philippe est un peu transparent
après je suis pas sûr que qu'emmanuel
macro et envies conduit et qu'on lui
fasse qu'on lui fasse de l'ombre
daniel bilalian il me revient sur la
phrase je suis toujours étonné
d'entendre des hommes politiques alors
qu'ils sont à peine là depuis cinq ou
six mois nous dire c'est pas tout de
suite c'est dans dix ans franchement le
français moyen qui coûte ça c'est
exactement comme le politiquement
correct comment voulez-vous que
j'accorde mon attention à monsieur le
maire qui me dit attendez l'a11 med en
disant ça je sais pas il ya quelque
chose qui dans leurs demeures
phraséologie il ya quelque chose qui me
qui meurent profondément qui meurent
qu'ils le pensent mais iront là mais les
gens attendent quelque chose les
français mais j'ai tendance à celle là
vous parlez de la forme et sur le fond
est ce que vous estimez que son action
politique états et le choix que j'ai et
s'il casse
c'est un ambitieux il a dit l'autre jour
j'ai moi même déjà été victime d'un
accident grave c'était lors de la
primaire des républicains il a il a pris
il a pris ce jour-là une défaite qui là
qu'il l'a marqué et je pense
qu'effectivement il a une ambition de
présidence de la république ça ça doute
pas m'avoir de premier ministre alors on
me dit qu edouard philippe et déjà
transparent bon attendons un peu le
dirait du mois le propos c'est comment
est-ce qu'on peut face aux français leur
dire attendez c'est pas maintenant si
c'est maintenant dont les a élus pour
maintenant les a pas élus pour dans dix
ans à propos du remaniement nous avons
un internaute prénommé hugo qui nous dit
macron vatan l'élection du président des
républicains pour remanier et silas
email de calan a réalisé un bon score il
le fera rentrer gouvernement vous pensez
que c'est possible de freiner la vie ça
se tient sur le papier puisque ce serait
en fait continuité avec édouard fille
qui s'est présentée je veux bien jamais
lors de la porte de sa transmission
allant de le passage de témoin avec
bernard cazeneuve
mais marquez d'un jeune homme de gauche
il s'est présenté comme un homme de
droite les a baptisés de droite sont
extrêmement satisfaits de la politique
de transformation économique et social
mené ça serait pour suivre cette chose
cette stratégie visant à casser la
droite et ce qu'il a besoin de prendre
d'autres personnalités alors que c'est
vrai qu'il ya le sentiment d'un
déséquilibre entre le et gauche et
droite qu'il a un petit peu plus sur la
droite mais il faut bien voir que dans
les enquêtes d'opinion
si je mets de côté les sympathisants de
la france a soumis ce qui sont critiques
depuis le début
chez les sympathisants socialistes faute
de réceptacle aux sentiments d'une
politique menée qui n'est pas très juste
c'est tjrs là encore on a toujours un
plus tôt un socle le socle électoral de
d'emmanuel macron de la présence elle
tient et c'est même élargi il n'a pas
perdu vraiment à gauche mais il s'est
élargi à droite oui ça serait une sorte
de continuité maintenant est-ce qu'il a
besoin d'un remaniement si vite ce comme
je le disais on n'a pas l'impression que
la machine god mental a des ratés comme
elle en avait il ya cinq ans il ya dix
ans il y avait énormément de quad parce
qu'ils avaient des poids lourds dans le
gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy c'est
une question qui se pose peut déjà qu'il
ya plus de pensée politique ces jeux le
paris saint germain veut pas de moi je
passe à l'as monaco petit jeu pour
terminer quel est selon vous le meilleur
ministre en exercice actuellement daniel
bilalian bah je pense que c'est monsieur
le maire alexandre je pense que c'est
jean michel blanc car sur le fond assure
sur le fond c'est jean michel blanckaert
fneg la vie dans les enquêtes d'opinion
c'est nicolas hulot mais c'est plus de
la popularité que derrag et crédibilité
à droite c'est très clairement un effet
bancaire qui est assez impressionnant
berti vaya meilleur meilleur ministre en
exercice actuellement merci beaucoup
pour ce débat nous allons passer au
second débat faut-il sauve le sauver en
gala merkel après la victoire très
relatifs de la cd ou aux législatives de
septembre
la chancelière temps de composer une
alliance avec les libéraux et avec les
écologistes les socialistes ayant fait
savoir qu'ils ne souhaitaient pas à
nouveau participer à cette coalition
or il semble que cette coalition
baptisée jamaïque et plus que du plomb
dans l aile comme le reconnaissait hier
à la fois la chancelière et des règles
et présente de la cd ou anglais marqué
mme merkel et le patron des libéraux
christian lindner on les écoute tout de
suite en juillet août
cet échec nous plonge dans une panique
totale
et si l'europe existaient demain sans
merkel qu allons vous faire qu'allons
nous devenir inquiétant ou est peut-être
à sion verte' vous qui suivait de près
les questions économiques et dieu sait
s'il y en a entre la france et
l'allemagne
comment envisager envisagez-vous cette
perspective vraiment je n'envisage pas
le pire je dis pas que ce soit le pire
mais en tout cas je ne l'enterrerai pas
trop vite politiquement que la merkel la
situation qui à travers cela est
effectivement compliqué je demande à
voir ce qui se passera dans les jours et
les semaines qui viennent et la capacité
qu'elle aura ou non à mener
d'autres pourparlers de coalition parce
qu'on n'est quand même pas tout à fait
aux rues de l'histoire l'on voit bien
qu'il ya une pression sur les libéraux
qui est en train de s'exercer de façon
très forte
on a une pression aussi qui est en train
de monter sur le spd son ancien
partenaire de coalition si pourrait
revenir dans le jeu qui pourrait revenir
dans le martin schulz qui a mené le spd
pendant les législatives est très
hostile à cette possibilité et son
prédécesseur qui depuis est devenu
président de la république allemande et
qui a aujourd'hui une fonction un peu
d'autorité morale acheter le maya plus
tôt pour parler d'une nouvelle élection
parce qu'il veut pas que j'allais
toujours hâte mais voilà effectivement
il ya car élément nouveau qui arrivait
de ranger aux dernières élections qui
devaient arriver de l'afd de l'extrême
droite au parlement allemand qui met
effectivement tous les acteurs
sous pression pour éventuellement
essayer de trouver une nouvelle
coalition et on connaît le talent
tactique dans gala merkel galerie seul
qui vient d'annoncer que s'il y avait
des élections anticipées elles seraient
à nouveau candidate non sa 1re balle et
cartes quand même
aussi c'est à dire qu'elle est prête à
aller de retourner devant retourner
devant les électeurs c'est qu'elle croit
en son étoile oui elle est quand même
sur une logique moi ou le chaos c'est
vrai que il ya eu une attitude très
forte en allemagne tout ce qui se passe
pour réactiver année mais un imaginaire
mortifère pour les allemands qui n'ont
pas connu un appui depuis la
construction de la rfa à savoir une
instabilité politique forte en mai
dernier gouvernement de la république de
weimar jusqu'à la victoire d'une du du
parti nazi cd gouvernement qui reste
très peu de temps et une impossibilité
de construire des majorités c'est vrai
que ça peut beaucoup inquiété et qu'elle
peut elle peut seulement elle peut se
poser comme le garant d'une certaine
unité politique en allemagne c'est vrai
qu'on est sur quelque chose je crois
d'inédits cette difficulté à former
localement mais c'est la première fois
qu'il n'y a pas de partenaire mais trois
voire quatre
donc c'est ce qui explique aussi c'est
de difficultés entre les parties
extrêmement différent entre les verts et
le fdp il n'y a quand même très très peu
de choses à voir mais il a répondu à
steiner justement cet après-midi en
disant je préfère des élections
anticipées un gouvernement minoritaire
je ne t'entends et les gouvernants
minoritaire quand vous l'avez dit qu'ils
étaient proches de weimar et on était un
petit peu à la source de sa classe perry
on serait dans un gouvernement
majoritaire
oui si mais le spd lui et n'a pas très
envie de rentrer quand même pas très
unie sur ce sujet alexandre vécu ou
est-ce que angela merkel paie quand même
ses déclarations sur sur les réfugiés il
ya quelques années parce que le un des
thèmes centraux de la rupture avec les
libéraux c'est ça c'est les libéraux
disent on veut pas aller au delà de 200
mille réfugiés par an et pas de
regroupement familial alors que les
écologistes le réclamer que finalement
cette cette parole qu'elle a prononcé il
ya quelques années pour dire il faut
accueillir bien en train de le payer
très cher oui je pense qu'elle a
d'ailleurs fabriqué la fp qui est le
parti populiste la wii avant la fdc le
parti n'y arrivais plus partie des
médias la sp mail
l'idée est donc le parti le parti
populiste
d'une certaine manière elle est là elle
a fabriqué avec cette question de
devenir les vins d'ouvrir les vannes de
l'immigration ce qui est intéressant
c'est le bouleversement politique
partout en europe et même en occident on
voit les coups de semonce les uns après
les autres
trump teresa le break 6 theresa may
macro est également une surprise donc on
voit les clivages traditionnels exploser
peu à peu on disait que l'allemagne
était le dernier pôle de stabilité
on voit là que c'est pas vraiment le cas
et que souvent ça se fracture sur les
questions effectivement identitaire et
donc les questions liées à l'immigration
daniel bilalian vous a le sentiment
qu'on a quand même toujours besoin de
angela merkel comme pôle de stabilité en
europe et que son départ éventuel de du
gouvernement allemand je préfère une
crise depuis plusieurs années c'est
quand même elle qui tient elle se tient
sur ses épaules l'europe telle qu'elle
est je pense malgré tout que les
divergences entre les différents partis
politiques aujourd'hui ne vont pas
faciliter à un gouvernement tel qu'on
l'imaginé je ris parce que on parle du
problème posé le problème majeur de
merkel s'est effectivement son problème
avec l'immigration c'est ce que c'est ce
qui a provoqué la situation actuelle
principalement et l'émergence de
l'extrême droite mais il ya aussi les
problèmes des énergies fossiles par
exemple avec les écologistes les
charbons d'allemagne à 1 a réduit 5 ans
de la construction centrale nucléaire
elle a même terminé la construction de
centrales nucléaires
deuxièmement il ya des problèmes fiscaux
aussi dont on ne parle beaucoup moins
qu'ils se posent notamment les nouveaux
veulent faire baisser encore blessés et
certains considèrent que l'allemagne de
l'est
enfin l'ancienne allemagne de l'est est
encore relativement mal traité je pense
que lorsque deux lancers à la turquie
non le voilà ça va quand même être très
difficile jeudi à imaginer qu'en france
on veut une fournée un gouvernement avec
benoît hamon la garde de lui des i et
les centristes ou laurent wauquiez s'est
pas jouée d'avancé venir jouer d'avant
mais il ya une tradition allemande de
coalition sas et demi ça c'est déjà la
fin des 120 je suis pas je crois je
pense que vous allez dire ce qui se
passe en allemagne montre six ans par
relief la solidité de nos institutions
c'est vrai que quand on regarde le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ces quatre forces à
autour de 24%
fillon dont il a été question ce
week-end qui échoue à quatre cent mille
voix et ben ça n'a pas fait empêché un
second tour très large et puis une
confirmation par les élections
législatives je ne dis pas que c'est
mieux ou moins bien mais en termes de
capacité de l'institution gaulliste à
dégager des majorités claires c'est une
vraie un vrai contraste par rapport à
l'allemagne
la seule chose qui me rend optimiste
c'est que les allemands sont protestants
pas tous non en bavière justement la
saison passée protestants donc il ya
toujours possibilité de d'un compromis
relisant je n'ai pas compris catholiques
comme la nôtre oui monde est-ce que vous
avez l'impression labertit bayen
certains journaux disent qu'elle était
trop souvent trop longtemps soul sur le
pont angela merkel et que du coup les
sous-officiers ont pris le pouvoir
pendant qu'elle était sur le pont ils en
ont profité pour faire des petites manas
où j'ai l'impression qu'elle s'est isolé
de son propre parti de sa propre base
pas seulement sur le thème de
l'immigration mais mais en général on a
le sentiment que pour le coup ça son
parti elle le tient plutôt pas mal et
après douze ans de pouvoir il ya quand
même une résilience qui est assez forte
et que pas mal de nos hommes politiques
pourraient pourraient lui envier
voilà après la difficulté elle
effectivement vis-à-vis de l'opinion
avec ce petit revers qu'elle aille aux
élections législatives mais bon malgré
tout c'est quand même la télé ou qui est
sorti en tête de ces législatives
après un nouveau donjon de pouvoir c'est
quand même pas négligeable
donc elle tient quand même plutôt bien
les choses après sa difficulté à faire
des coalitions je reviens sur la
première question que vous me posiez
effectivement je pense que c'est un
problème pour l'europe et c'est d'autant
plus un problème pour l'europe que on a
cette instabilité nouvelle en allemagne
qui intervient comme le disait alexandre
à un moment où on a aussi la grande
bretagne qui est profondément
déstabilisé par le brr exit ou l'espagne
est profondément déstabilisé par la
crise car malade
voilà ça fait quand même une addition de
crise européenne qui ont des motifs
différents duc en europe de l'est les
mouvements populistes
évidemment train de rêver d'un banc ne
pouvait mais si on se concentre sur
l'europe de l'ouest et sur les
principaux piliers de
de la construction européenne avec même
un petit peu quand même le march
alors justement la question du jour
aussi posée aux internautes du figaro
portait sur 7 sur angela merkel si on
peut l'avoir souhaitez-vous qu'angela
merkel se maintiennent au pouvoir en
allemagne et lors les français alors ce
n'est pas un sondage frédéric dabi vous
entends déjà juste la question du jour
du figaro une consultation exactement il
ya eu un sondage d'ailleurs en allemagne
qui est intéressant mais un vrai sondage
comme les vôtres qui disait que 60% des
allemands estimaient que s'il ya un
échec des négociations il fallait
qu'elle quitte le pouvoir donc on n'a
pas tout à fait mais ma vie et peut-être
que les français on trouve chez merkel
quelque chose de rassurant
c'est ça c'est ça l'idée à votre avis
alors oui sans doute même si dans toutes
les enquêtes le même si on n'appelle pas
abouti je pense en allemagne mais elle a
une très bonne note de popularité auprès
de l'ensemble des français même si
l'ifop fait régulièrement des enquêtes
pour l'ambassade d'allemagne et le
sentiment d'un couple franco-allemand
déséquilibré
c'est d'année en année renforcé et
notamment pendant la période 2012-2017
hollande peut-être qu'il ya une aussi
une dimension aux opportunités avec ce
qui vient d'être rappelée sur les crises
que connaissent les autres pays
européens
sk pas une opportunité historique pour
la france et même macron on l'a vu cela
de travailleurs détachés même si
l'accord est beaucoup moins glorieux que
ce qu'il paraît de prendre le lead et de
de faire revenir cette vision hugolienne
qu'on beaucoup de français de l'europe
c'est à dire l'europe c'est la france en
gros on n'en est pas là mais il ya une
opportunité mais je pense que
fondamentalement paradoxalement les
français ont peut-être envie que angela
merkel reste parce que ça reste un point
d'appui alors que nous avons ce revenu
sous françois hollande une période comme
on irait jt délicate un an sans
transition je dis bien sans transition
nous passons de l'allemagne à marine le
pen avec cette proposition assez
peut-être curieuse peut-être
provocatrice vous nous direz tout à leur
formuler ce week-end à l'endroit de
laurent wauquiez je vous propose de la
réécouter c'était au grand jury rtl ce
week-end ce dimanche j'entends le
discours de monsieur wauquiez
aujourd'hui je me dis mais après tout
s'il est sincère je parle sous votre
contrôle s'il est sincère compte tenu
des propos qu'il tient mais il devrait à
jusqu'à proposer une alliance et
politiques devront tenir des propos
comme il les tient il faut qu'il aille
au bout de sa logique
ou alors ou alors ils démontrent qu'en
réalité ces propos ne sont pas sincères
que ce sont des propos destin alors
c'est peut-être une provocation mais
frédéric dabi est ce que marine le pen
n'a pas mis ce week-end des mots sur une
réalité dont les français sont plutôt
plus tôt conscience et il ya une
proximité idéologique entre les
électorats front national et les écoles
et l'électorat déjà l'an pas sur tous
les sujets sur les questions économiques
il ya des vraies différences sur
l'europe mais pas conserver sur les
questions identité insécurité
immigration on avait parlé à l'ifop mon
ami jérôme fourquet délectera en fusion
maintenant les propos de marine le pen
sont clairement sidérant parce qu'ils
sont en rupture totale avec ce qu'elle
disait ya à peine quinze jours ce qu'a
toujours dit par exemple jean marie le
pen face à nicolas sarkozy que dit le
front national lorsque un homme
politique une femme politique de droite
venir braconné pour récupérer les
électeurs de droite passée au fn ou
comme nicolas sarkozy en 2007
faire revenir à droite les électeurs de
jean-marie le pen 2002 le fn dit ce
n'est pas il vous trompe ce qu'il vous
dit il ne le fera pas et quand il sera
au pouvoir et c'est ce qu'a dit marine
le pen ya à peine quinze jours trois
semaines
il freine politique européiste de centre
gauche on est ce que c'est pas le signe
aussi d'une marine le pen aux abois qui
provoque énormément la parole dans les
médias alors qu'elle n'a rien à dire je
le rappelle qu'elle a annoncé une
consultation des adhérents frontistes
pour février mars
elle est peut-être peut-être sur enfin
c'est un signe supplémentaire de la
crise peut-être personnel et de la crise
que connaît ce parti parce que cette
main tendue ça veut dire quoi
alors c'est un piège peut-être un petit
peu trop visible elle ne sera bien sûr
pas relevé par laurent wauquiez qui l'a
bien dit lui veut parler aux électeurs
du front national
mais elle fait un virage à 180 degrés
entre ce discours de tromperie on se
moque de vous et elle propose une
alliance donc ça peut c'est quand même
des propos assez surprenant daniel
bilalian vous croyez que ça c'est une
des conséquences du départ de florian
philippot de se permettre de ce genre de
ce genre de proposition je crois que
rien qu'à la voir s'exprimer comme ça on
ne juge pas les gens aux apparences mais
sont rarement trompeuse on sent qu'elle
est elle est perdue elle cherche quelque
chose elle cherche à s'appuyer sur sur
une idée qui la fera mettre en valeur et
c'est moi je pense pas une seule seconde
que d'abord je pense pas que laurent
wauquiez va lui va lui répondre
il attend ce qui devrait ou pendant un
an je pense qu'il devrait pas il a fait
deux choses très intelligentes ces
derniers temps c'est qu'il n'a pas
accepté un débat télévisé que dû
progresser ses concurrents ça il a très
très bien fait parce que il aurait fait
comme la dernière fois aux primaires
certains ont confondu une élection
primaire et une élection générale
il a très bien joué il joue très bien
effectivement il s'adresse aux électeurs
égarés qui ont voté front national sur
les problèmes identitaires sur lequel
effectivement la droite et le front
national sont parfois assez proche mais
ça va bien au delà d'ailleurs parce que
le problème d'identité elle touche tous
les français même aujourd'hui les
partisans emmanuel macron lui réclame un
discours un peu plus sérieux sur le
problème de l'immigration
c'est un problème qui concerne tous les
français je pense que laurent wauquiez
se laissera pas se laissera pas tentée
il a joué très intelligemment jusqu'à
jusqu'à présent et pour l'instant la
voie royale lui et alexandre de vécu ou
qui avait enquêté sur dans votre livre
les nouveaux enfants du siècle sur les
jeunesses de france toutes les jeunesses
de france vous avez senti cette porosité
idéologique entre d'éventuels électeurs
du front national et des lecteurs de la
droite classique
oui c'est dans la jeunesse elle et elle
est totale c'est d'ailleurs amusant
total 40 on va six ans qu on a des dites
fin il ya plus du tout d'ailleurs de
diabolisation entre en train
souverainistes de gauche et le minent
le front national on voit bien que même
des mélenchonistes discuter avec avec le
front national
il ya quelqu'un qui est très apprécié
dans la jeunesse qui incarne cette cette
fusion des daurades c'est marion
maréchal le pen donc c'est une certitude
les électeurs de demain se
positionneront papa par rapport au
clivage droite gauche traditionnelle cn
génération la première élection qu'elle
a vu c'est l'élection
le référendum sur le traité européen en
2005 et on parlait des questions
identitaires la même année il ya eu les
émeutes de banlieues quand je les
intéresse et les deux événements qui
ressortait qui ont structuré leur
imaginaire politique l'europe d'un côté
les questions d'identité de l'autre et
je crois que le clivage du futur va
vraiment se faire sur le rapport à la
mine et de mondialisation
macron incarne parfaitement une
électorat des grandes métropoles ouvert
à la mondialisation celui qui va bien et
je crois que celui qui parviendra à être
sont à un adversaire politique ce sera
celui qui parviendra à rassembler la
france périphérique
celle qui est justement qui souffrent de
l'insécurité physique culturelle mais
aussi économique donc je pense qu'il va
falloir réfléchir à une forme de
protectionnisme intégrale de la part du
candidat qui voudra être l'adversaire
d'emmanuel m'amener pour autant à ce que
laurent wauquiez doit répondre à marine
le pen d'une manière ou d'une autre
quitte à lui envoyé une fin de non
recevoir mais ce qui doit lui répondre
et ce qui va entrer dans ce jeu là ne
pas le faire est ce que c'est pas
prendre un risque aussi de de mépris qui
peut être mal interprétés je pense qu'il
a tout intérêt mois
à ne pas le faire puisque ce il surjoue
l'opposition marine le pen en fixant
ligne rouge total il risque de perdre
une partie justement de cet électorat
populaire qui hésitent à le rejoindre
parce que il ya un soupçon de la
sincérité et c'est là où je pense que
marine le pen a passé sa part a par
hasard elle a voulu justement le faire
apparaître comme un faux dur c'est la
question aujourd'hui qui se pose pour
cet électorat là et ça va être toute la
difficulté de laurent wauquiez moi je
trouve qu'il fait une campagne très
sarkozy 2007
or on n'avait que sarkozy en 2007 a
réussi à massaise peut-être à mettre le
fonds national à 10%
mais ensuite face à l'exercice du
pouvoir c'est aussi l'homme de traité de
lisbonne le front national est revenu
plus fort que jamais donc on ne refera
pas le coup deux fois à cet électorat là
et où laurent wauquiez à mon avis va
devoir être extrêmement cohérent pour
convaincre cet électorat là de revenir
vers la droite
bertille d'ailleurs vous avez le
sentiment que vraiment ce qui
différencie aujourd'hui de républicaine
fonctionnel c'est seulement laissant
seulement les questions économiques le
reste c'est très poreux ça se passe
beaucoup sur les sujets économiques est
effectivement un certain rapport à
l'économie est la montée surface je je
je je conçois qu'on ait plus de porosité
les limites dans la jeunesse entre
parfois l'extrême gauche et l'extrême
droite qu'effectivement on peut se
rejoindre sur des envies de
protectionnisme par rapport à un coeur
historique de droite libéral droite
centriste et même un petit peu plus que
ça donc là effectivement on a déjà des
divisions qui sont fades et des lignes
de fracture qui soit un petit peu plus
compliqué plus compliqué que semble mais
ouais enfin je trouve qu'effectivement
la marine le pen tend un piège un petit
peu quand même hein à laurent wauquiez
parce qu'effectivement elle le ramène
sur un sujet dont les républicains
arrivé depuis je prendrai après 48
heures à s'extraire
là elle revient de là dessus et les
oblige de nouveau à débattre de cette
question est ce qu'on est pour est-ce
qu'on est contre l'alliance avec le
front national et ça empêche le débat
j'ai les républicains de le voter je
veux pas le tort que ça ferait alors ok
de ne pas lui répondre au niveau où elle
est actuellement je pense que sans son
sens montrer comment dirais je
indélicats sont des gages il a pas lui
répondre il a fallu répondre
il a déjà fait il l'a déjà fait en
disant je ne veux pas le problème
aujourd'hui 2 est le seul fait qu'elle
ne fasse à limone je veux dire quand on
remet dans le match son électorat c'est
quoi le problème de lectorat de laurent
wauquiez si le problème des français
s'il ya un chercheur américain qui dans
votre journal le figaro il ya quelques
temps avait fait une étude en ligne a
plus que deux catégories de gens dans le
monde
les sommes ware et les nuers les sommes
versées moi c'est à dire je suis pas
contre le progrès mais j'ai envie de
travailler chez moi et appartenir à
quelque chose à un pays et les aînés
were c'est ce qu'ils proche de macron au
travail dans les open space entre deux
escales cela ils sont tout à fait enfin
ses mac os dans son nectar
non j'aurais quand même aimé et je pense
que notre ami wauquiez dans l'occurrence
c'est awesome ware qui doit qu'il doit
seul et c'est quand même la majorité
encore c'est encore la majorité des
français et à propos de somewhere je
vous propose d'écouter les adieux de
françois fillon fillon avant ce week-end
qui est justement était plutôt dans
cette catégorie des gens qui se voulait
enraciné lorsqu'il a fait campagne et
qui faisait qui passait la main à bruno
retailleau ce week-end son mouvement
forces républicaines on ne comprend rien
à la civilisation moderne écrivait
georges bernanos
si l'on admet pas d'abord qu'elle est
une conspiration contre toute espèce de
vie intérieure et bien l'avertissement
doit être entendu alors il faut savoir
prendre du recul c'est ce que je fais en
redevenant un citoyen un citoyen qui
n'oublie rien qui ne renie rien mais
surtout un citoyen qui aime son pays et
qui du fond du coeur vous dit merci
vive la république
ville alors c'est très chic de cité
georges bernanos a dû vous faire plaisir
l'ex ont donné que vous donner des
regrets d'avoir quitté la scène
politique
oui je trouve qu'il a fait preuve
peut-être de plus d'élégance que du
hauran après le premier tour de la
présidentielle où il s'est précipité
pour appeler à voter
emmanuel macron sont même quasiment un
mot pour ses électeurs qu'il avait
parfois soutenues au contre vents et
marées maintenant ce qui est intéressant
c'est ce que va devenir forces
républicaines son mouvement je pense que
bruno retailleau a pas de volonté le
personnel quoi ils ne s'imaginent pas un
destin national par contre si c'est un
intellectuel en politique c'est
quelqu'un qui lit c'est quelqu'un qui
n'est pas simplement dans la droite
gestionnaire est économiste et je pense
que forces républicaines peut devenir
une sorte de think tank l'île des
républicains un aiguillon et janick
d'avis vous avez noté que françois
fillon ne soutient ni florence portelli
qui était une des fidèles parmi les
fidèles et qui se présente contre
laurent wauquiez ni a fortiori laurent
wauquiez si tenté qu'il soutenait
quelqu'un ce serait un cadeau empoisonné
selon vous pour le pour un candidat de
droite je pense que les français sont
passés à autre chose après la défaite de
françois fillon qui reste toujours très
impopulaire il n'y a pas eu de relecture
a posteriori de bienveillance de no2 de
nostalgie dans les enquêtes mais
toujours un tiers de personnes pour une
bonne opinion de tiers de mauvaises à
droite ce n'est pas formidable
il aurait pu c'est vrai soutenir laurent
wauquiez qui a été son soutien il ya
cinq ans on est à cinq ans presque jour
pour jour de la fameuse élection copie
fillon ii du 19 août du 20 novembre 2000
il aurait pu également mais personne n'a
oublié compris le journal que je pense à
faire le pied de grue jour et nuit
devant le siège d'aéroports et de
l'obliger oui voilà c'est ça oui et puis
et florence procès dit qu'il a vraiment
faim sous de plus de manière extrêmement
fidèle en tout cas la droite qu'a connu
françois fillon est celle que l'on voit
à thème actuellement n'est plus du tout
la même avec des constructif avec cette
implosion avec le fait on ne l'a pas dit
mais laurent wauquiez dans la dernière
enquête il faut fête du sel pour match
perd une dizaine de points chez les
sympathisants des républicains en
gagnant 15 15
chez les sympathisants du front national
d'où aussi cette scène
sans doute à mort entre l air et le
front national on est toujours six mois
après la présidentielle dans un contexte
de décomposition recomposition y compris
à droite
dernier thème je voudrais qu'on revienne
sur cette polémique tout sauf fumeuse
qui a agité le week-end les internautes
les téléspectateurs un peu tout le monde
cette interpellation sénat par une élue
de la sarthe nadine grelet certenais qui
a été reprise par agnès buzyn à propos
de l'interdiction de la cigarette au
cinéma complètement ce qui a été dit par
madame la députée sur le cinéma français
je veux qu'on ait une action ferme là
dessus je ne comprends pas aujourd'hui
la halle à l'importance de la cigarette
dans le cinéma français et dont il se
trouve que j'en ai parlé au conseil des
ministres ce matin à madame françoise
nyssen pour l'alerter et donc il y aura
des mesures en ce sens alors nous a
rejoints sur le plateau jean baptiste
émergents qui scrute avec sa grosse
loupe écrans petits et grands pour nous
qui ont beaucoup régis week-end les gens
beaucoup réagit sur c'est sur cette
affaire avec des choses parfois très
sérieux et parfois très drôle à la fois
sur twitter sur les réseaux sociaux un
peu partout à propos de cette
interdiction possible de la cigarette au
cinéma oui environ un millier de tweets
dans le week-end sur ce sujet
effectivement beaucoup d'effervescence
et de critique beaucoup de critiques sur
ce sujet il faut savoir que sa date
quand même de 2015 la ministre de la
santé de l'époque michèle delaunay en
avait déjà un petit peu parlé et elle
avait été beaucoup critiqué j'avais un
tweet de fabien qui disait que donc
michel données il est indispensable que
la loi evin soit appliquée par les films
sur les films français et ceux fabien
qu'ils aient une vision bien
particulière de ce qu'est l'art et donc
il y avait une critiques continuelles et
des milliers des militants et alipio et
ça continue mais bon faut savoir qu'à
l'époque dans 80% des films français il
y avait la présence de tabac et
maintenant cette année enfin plutôt dans
les derniers films c'est 70% donc on
peut dire qu'il ya une sorte de baisse
effectivement il ya une sorte de
progression bon après on peut dire qu'en
2010 le film sur serge gainsbourg était
sorti avec 49 minutes de cigarettes et
interventions deux heures de film en
même temps en 2015 finissait les sept
saisons de la série mad men où il y
avait 100 foot 940 et une cigarette qui
avait été filmée et je vous parle même
pas de touriste qui a été vu donc voilà
il ya une tension est effective
le milieu de l'art et cette obligation
ou non de cigarettes je vous ai vais
pouvoir parler tout à l'heure des 70%
donc j'ai trouvé quelques tweets rigolo
enfin rigolo en tout cas qui dénonce et
xavier beauvois lui propose exactement
et acteurs proposent l'oscar de la
connerie pour la ministre avec un savon
on peut le voir une cigarette et un
oscar césar c'est la césar à part dont
on a peut-être l'oscar un jour ça
d'autres le tank ailleurs 2011
voyez sauf si l'on achète sur l'amazone
est pas certes le l'écrivain et
journaliste au no christophe ono dit
biot lui s'inquiète sur la liberté de
création des écrivains est ce qu'une
bouteille est ce qu'on va pouvoir mettre
de l'alcool ou pas c'est ça aussi bien
mais concerné puisqu'une adaptation de
son roman plonge et qu'ils soient dans
quelques jours comment ils dwyer la
cigarette dedans il ya des charges et
décharges et de l'alcool voilà lui il
est plutôt sur cette critique là et
c'est vrai que c'est une critique qui
revient dans beaucoup de tweets qui est
là effectivement on parle du tabac mais
ça va être pourquoi pas des on va
arrêter les assassinats dans les films
etc etc
j'avais enfin une dernière explication
de francine giron forcing giron sort un
visuel assez rigolo avec deux une de
lucky luke
une avec un ricky lui qui donne une
fessée un petit garçon
donc là oui c'est très sain critique
c'est là on a deux deux sujets de
conversation avec tuer lille reste plus
que les bots parce que voilà on a pleuré
à nidau fait son nid de selon elle la
censure et vivent un peu plus tard henry
mais elle ajoute une censure dangereux
soleil même si ça part d'un bon
sentiment car il ya quand même une
sensibilisation à faire sur la cia
imaginez si en plus le culte budget
alors la série voilà une bonne nouvelle
de taille daniel bilalian à votre avis
mettre le paquet de cigarettes à 10
euros qui est quand même le début le
projet
engagé par le gouvernement d'où cette
discussion au sénat ce c'est pas
suffisant pour arrêter le tabac il faut
en arriver à ce que jean marie je pense
qu'il faut je pense que l'augmentation
est un élément suffisant je veux dire ce
que j'entends là c'est quelque chose de
grotesque parce que si on se rapporte au
cinéma ou même à la vie qui a été la
nôtre on n'aura plus le droit de boire
wiston churchill
on n'aura plus droit de voir charles de
gaulle jusque dans les années 50 bons
films mais pompidou je faisais la jeune
journaliste les rapports du conseil des
ministres il faisait clope au bec
il est comme ça c'est non il ya quelque
chose
moi je sais pas si on veut nous mettre
en face de nous une vie qui n'est pas la
nôtre qui n'est pas réel savez ça me
fait penser aussi aux enfants
aujourd'hui on leur apprend à faire du
vélo ils ont des coudes des genouillères
des casques on en fait des momies par
ailleurs on vit dans une société on vit
dans une société d'une violence inouïe
on est en pleine lutte contre le
terrorisme et quand j'entends dire il
faut abandonner la cigarette au cinéma
c'est dramatique c'est moi je considère
que la cigarette et c'est quelque chose
de mauvais fumée mais regardez jusqu'à
il ya dix ans avant que ce soit interdit
pour un monsieur qui travaillait comme
maçon plâtrier sur sur un chantier le
midi entre midi et deux heures ils
venaient dans un café bien au chaud
boire son café mais fumer sa cigarette
aujourd'hui les sous l'abribus par moins
15 hockey voilà c'est très bien on
s'occupe de lui on se crise de lui
s'occupe de lui contre son gré ou
alexandre et vécurent ses traits au
moyen comme initiative fait orwelliens
les systèmes totalitaires trafic et les
photos changer les images donc un peu
sans se demande où est ce que ça va
s'arrêter peut-être demain on va limiter
la vitesse dans fast and furious
interdire le sexe pour incitation au
harcèlement ou ou à la débauche
donc arrêtons de vivre c'est ça qu'on
veut c'est parce que la vie tu donc
voilà je crois que ça cache
effectivement alors il ya une peau sont
possibles dérives totalitaires sa cache
aussi la grande impuissance des
politiques qui n'arrive pas à régler les
réels problèmes des gens et qui
finalement se concentre sur des choses
comme ça anecdotique donc j'ai envie de
dire comme georges pompidou arrêtez
d'emmerder les français liberty buy ins
et quand même 80 mille morts par an du
tabac donc il faut quand même prendre
des prend des décisions donc on sait que
le gouvernement est dans son rôle quand
il lance comme ça des sons des
initiatives de ce type
cette piste-là clairement elle est bonne
celle qui a une politique très déterminé
notion d'accord ça c'est clair
l'augmentation violents des prix du prix
des cigarettes c'est à ce stade la
meilleure façon qu'on ait trouvé
d'empêcher nous voulons de fumer et je
suis bien placé pour le savoir
donc ça effectivement il faut le faire
sur le cinéma évidemment
ça n'a pas de sens dans le sens où un le
cinéma peut être un reflet la réalité
s'ils arrêtent la cigarette et fait
partie de cette réalité 2 il ya la
liberté de création il ya juste un petit
point quand même sur lequel je serai
curieuse d'avoir une réponse je ne l'est
pas c'est de savoir dans quelle mesure
il ya des politiques de la part des
fabricants de tabac de placement produit
ou là il peut y avoir là on peut avoir
là on peut avoir une action
public pour l'empêcher de la même façon
qu'on empêche la publicité etc
le placement produit est une forme de
marketing via le cinéma et contribuer le
cas échéant à cette image pour
l'associer au tabac la cigarette qui
peut avoir de l'influencé sur les jeunes
cette image de liberté d'émancipation
etc et c'est vrai que c'est ce jeu voilà
sans nuire à la liberté de création
c'est une question qu'il faut se poser
je dis pas qu'elles appellent à une
politique publique évidemment
d'interdiction de la cigarette dans les
films mais se poser la question de
savoir
malgré tout ce qu'on fait malgré tout ce
qu'on dit pourquoi est-ce que la
cigarette continue à véhiculer cette
image là c'est un sujet le placement
produit c'est une réalité dans les
années 60 on disait que le whisky avait
été largement importée en france grâce
au film d'elie constantine avec dhabi un
dernier mot je crois que c'est vous qui
est le plus remonté sur cette idée tout
ce qui a été dit ce qui est intéressant
de voir c'est que toutes les politiques
publiques d'interdiction du tabac par
exemple dans les lieux publics en 2006
cinq minutes on était soutenu
massivement par les français y compris
par les fumeurs là c'est vrai qu'il ya
un côté un petit peu dérisoire et on ne
sait plus jusqu'où on va aller pourquoi
pas notamment pourquoi pas forcé des
acteurs à manger cinq fruits et légumes
pendant les films pour ma part sur un
conte mettre sur un court métrage ça
peut être un peu difficile mais en tout
cas voilà je pense que c'est extrêmement
est vraiment dérisoire
ce qui n'empêche pas quoi là la question
des 80 mille morts est un vrai sujet on
se souvient que en 2002 jacques chirac
avait dans ses trois grands sujets trois
grandes campagnes et à il ya eu des
résultats réels et m'assurer pas en se
focalisant sur des moyens aussi
dérisoire merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à ce point de vue très
riche
rendez vous demain se le figurer live
même jour enfin pas même jour mais même
heure même lieu même punition à demain
[Musique]